d'une autorité et plus encore quand elle
est indépendante de
d'être disponible pour répondre aux
questions de à des assemblées
sur nos propres décisions ça va sans
dire mais également pour échanger sur
l'évolution du secteur et les évolutions
possibles
donc je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
à répondre à vos questions sur le
processus d'examen par l'Autorité de la
concurrence du projet d'achat par le
groupe Bouygues propriétaire de TF1 du
groupe métropole télévision qui est le
propriétaire de la chaîne M6 et
naturellement d'autres acteurs dans ce
processus et
particulièrement l'arcom mais je sais
que vous auditionnez le président de
LARCOM demain donc il y a des questions
auxquelles je ne pourrais probablement
pas répondre car elles sont plutôt de
son ressort et je suis accompagné par
monsieur Étienne Chantrel qui est le
chef du service des concentrations de
l'Autorité de la concurrence qui a donc
piloté ce processus
alors les risques d'atteinte à la
concurrence que vous avez commencé à
évoquer monsieur le Président ont été
résumés dans notre commune de du 16
septembre je vais pas tellement y
revenir dans mon introduction liminaire
mais je suis évidemment prêt à y revenir
en plus d'autant plus de détails et je
voudrais dire un mot comme vous m'y
invitez monsieur le Président sur le
processus qui a été suivi
le contrôle des concentrations et une
des quatre missions principales de
l'Autorité de la concurrence avec la
répression des pratiques
anticoncurentielles
avec notre rôle dans la régulation de
certaines professions réglementées du
droit les notaires les commissaires de
justice
notamment
et avec notre fonction consultative sous
forme de saisine d'office ou de en
réponse au saisines du gouvernement et
du Parlement sur lequel on est
évidemment toujours à votre disposition
alors le contrôle des concentrations est
régi par le titre 3 du livre 4 du Code
de commerce les articles l430 1 L 430 10
et au niveau européen
qui n'est pas le sujet principal ici
mais comme vous allez certainement avoir
des questions sur la suite du processus
l'Europe reviendra dans le jeu au niveau
européen le contrôle des concentrations
et régie par le règlement 139004
et
tout cela est détaillé dans des lignes
directrices que l'Autorité de la
Concurrence a publié en
réviser en juillet 2020
donc les principales phases de l'examen
du dossier ont été les suivantes
d'abord il a été
constaté que l'opération était de la
compétence de l'autorité de la
concurrence et non de la Commission
européenne
car les deux entreprises concernées
réalisées plus de deux tiers de leur
chiffre d'affaires européens à
l'intérieur d'un seul État membre qui
est la France donc
le ça n'a pas fait l'objet d'une grande
discussion c'était les l'application du
règlement conduisait à localiser ce
dossier à Paris
la phase de pré notification à partir de
mai 2021 donc de l'annonce de
l'opération par les par les parties a
été mise à profit par les services
d'instruction de l'autorité pour
réaliser des premiers actes
d'instruction des questionnaires envoyés
aux parties donc à TF1 et M6 plusieurs
dizaines de questionnaires envoyés aux
différents acteurs du secteur dans ce
qu'on appelle les tests de marché
des entretiens informels avec certains
de ces acteurs
et l'examen des premières études
économiques qui ont été produites pour
le compte de Bouygues sur notamment la
question de la définition du marché
pertinent donc ce travail a pu commencer
entre mai 2021 et la notification
formelle de l'opération qui a eu lieu le
17 février 2022
et parallèlement nous avons saisi un
formellement l'arcome et larcep ce qui a
conduit une finnée à la à la
transmission de deux avis qui qui ont
été rendus publics par ces autorités la
semaine dernière comme vous savez
l'opération a été notifiée le 17 février
par le groupe Bouygues le 18 mars
l'Autorité de la Concurrence a décidé
d'ouvrir une phase d'examen approfondie
donc dans les concentrations la très
grande majorité des opérations de
concentration notifiées à l'Autorité de
la concurrence font l'objet d'un examen
simple dit de phase 1 et sont autorisés
sans condition
c'est une très grosse volumétrie en 2021
272 opérations de concentration
autorisées dont une seule interdiction
qui était le projet d'acquisition de la
société du pipeline méditerranéeone par
le fond ardian
en 2022 et à la date d'hier
181 opérations ont été autorisées depuis
le début de l'année donc on est en passe
de battre le record d'activité de 2021
dont une seule à ce stade en face de qui
était le l'acquisition de Conforama par
but qui a été autorisé au printemps
donc ça vous donne une idée aussi de la
fin de la de la
de la l'importance relative des examens
en phase 2 et en phase 1 dans notre
activité c'est tout ça et très très
exceptionnel
et c'est on parle de quelques opérations
voire une ou deux opérations par an au
maximum
donc des avis formels ont été sollicités
auprès de l’arcome et de l'ARCEP des
échanges ont eu lieu également avec la
CNIL
l'examen approfondie a donné lieu à
l'envoi à Bouygues le 22 juillet d'un
rapport des services d'instruction qui
faisait plus de 400 pages
qui donc détaillé le
la situation sur les différents marchés
et il ne s'agit pas seulement du marché
de la publicité mais également et
principalement de deux autres marchés le
marché de la distribution de services de
télévision donc les relations avec les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet et les
autres distributeurs comme comme le haut
Canal+ et également les marchés
d'acquisition de contenu donc de
programme de flux et de films étrangers
ou français
bouillie a répondu le 12 août par des
observations a sorti d'une proposition
d'engagement
le rapport de l'instruction du 22
juillet a été confidentielle mais c'est
principal conclusions ont été rendues
publiques par les intérêts c'est-à-dire
par Bouygues M6 à la demande de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers parce
que c'était des informations que les
groupes ne pouvaient pas
cacher à leur à leurs actionnaires
les 5 et 6 septembre le collège de
l'Autorité de la concurrence serré unie
pendant deux jours plein nous avons
entendu des représentants des groupes
Bouygues et bartelsman bien sûr
des des principaux acteurs du secteur
donc les concurrents de TF1 de M6 chaîne
de télé chaîne de radio des
distributeurs des annonceurs des
producteurs également l'institut
Médiamétrie pour avoir une vision des
évolutions de l'audience y compris sur
les plateformes sur les plateformes en
ligne
et le commissaire du Gouvernement donc
la représentant de la Direction Générale
de la Concurrence et de la répression
des fraudes a été entendu comme pour
toutes séances de l'autorité
j'ajoute que le collège était réuni en
formation plénière ce qui est tout à
fait exceptionnel voir inédit et
refléter mon souhait d'avoir une
délibération la plus
complète et pluraliste possible sur un
sujet qui était manifestement très
complexe donc comme vous le savez le
collège de l'Autorité de la Concurrence
a composé de 17 membres 5 membres
permanents qui sont le président et
quatre vice-présidents qui sont
permanents et 12 membres non permanents
dont 17 membres qui ont des activités
soit dans l'administration la
magistrature ou le ou le monde de
l'entreprise sur ces 17 membres Doom 12
membres ont pu participer à la
délibération cinq membres se sont
récusés parce qu'ils avaient des
conflits d'intérêts potentiels directs
ou indirects
et je crois qu'il c'est la première fois
que
autant de membres du collège de
l'autorité siège en même temps pour
décider d'une opération de concentration
je pense que c'était jamais arrivé
[Musique]
et donc s'agissant d'un problème de
finalement de pouvoir de marcher pour
dire les choses en bon français dans
notre jargon on dit que c'est un
problème horizontal c'est tout
simplement le problème du pouvoir de
marché combiné des deux entités la seule
solution d'un point de vue concurrentiel
aurait consiste à des à des sessions et
contenu de l'ampleur du problème
concurrentiel la solution qui aurait pu
régler ce problème et qu'on aurait
consistait à céder une des principales
chaînes du groupe ce qui est évidemment
vider le projet de sa substance
quand on quand on lit que l'Autorité de
la Concurrence a demandé à
Bouygues de CD TF1 ou M6 ces forces
c'est formellement vrai mais ça revenait
en réalité le message aux entités aux
parties c'était en réalité que
l'autorité se dirige vers une
interdiction puisque nous étions
conscients du fait que ces remèdes
n'étaient pas possible pour eux
n'avaient pas de sens pour eux on n'a
pas sérieusement considéré que ils
allaient accepter cette ces remède qui
évidemment vider l'opération
complètement sa substance donc le débat
était sur une interdiction
et le même jour le soir Bouygues et
bartelsman ont annoncé leur intention de
retirer leur dossier ce qui a été
notifié formellement le lundi 19
septembre
avant de avant de répondre à vos
questions je voudrais peut-être ajouter
deux mots de conclusion sur le président
bon d'abord sur la substance du projet
il s'agissait d'une opération de
concentration de grande ampleur qui
aurait fait émerger un acteur
ultra dominant sur le marché de la
publicité et de la distribution en
France avec sur le marché de la
publicité plus de 70% de parts de marché
et donc la conséquence inévitable aurait
été une hausse des tarifs de publicité
une hausse des redevances versées par
les distributeurs et peut-être si on
peut en discuter une perte de diversité
des programmes qui auraient circulé qui
aurait pu circuler dans un ensemble plus
grand
et nous avons considéré que le
développement des services de vidéos à
la demande ne permettait pas à un
horizon prévisible de remettre en cause
la puissance des écrans de télévision
les les services de
vidéos à la demande en vocation à rester
des modèles payants contrairement aux
services édités par TF1 M6 et repose
avant tout sur une individualisation de
la de la consommation qui n'est pas
propice à la diffusion simultanée d'un
ange publicitaire auprès d'un très grand
nombre d'utilisateurs ce qui reste le
modèle de la publicité à la télé
alors je tiens à préciser que l'Autorité
de la concurrence ne lit pas la
pertinence industrielle du projet
c'est un projet qui aurait permis aux
parties c'est ce qu'en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elle nous ont exposé de développer
une plateforme une nouvelle plateforme
numérique qui aurait été proposé soit
dans les bouquets des distributeurs soit
directement au téléspectateurs sur
internet donc c'est un modèle Ott
télécommandé dans ce dans ce métier over
the top
comme une plateforme de vidéo à la
demande et qui leur aurait permis de
mieux valoriser les contenus achetés par
les chaînes
et je crois qu'au vu de notre pratique
décisionnelle des dernières années et
même j'ajouterai les derniers mois
vis-à-vis des grandes plateformes
numériques je crois pas que l'Autorité
de la concurrence puisse être suspecté
de myopie ou de complaisance face aux
grandes plateformes
américaines ni de d'ignorer les
évolutions technologiques je cite
simplement pour les derniers mois la
décision
sur le les services de publicité de
Google de 120 millions d'euros d'amende
la décision sur le la gestion des droits
voisins par Google 500 millions d'euros
d'amende et à la suite de cette amende
des engagements contraignants de Google
pour la première fois en Europe et même
au monde si on met si on écarte
l'Australie
la décision sur les services de
l'intermédiation de publicité de
facebook donc aller sur la saisine de
Crito qui est aussi conduit meta donc
Facebook apprendre des engagements
contraignant auprès d'une autorité de
concurrence pour la première fois au
monde à notre connaissance
l'étude en cours sur le Cloud etc donc
nous nous sommes des observateurs
attentifs des évolutions technologiques
mais on l'espèce notre conclusion a été
que ce projet industriel aurait une
finesse été financée par les annonceurs
français et donc par les consommateurs
et par les téléspectateurs et que les
gains de
déficiences qui leur proposait pour les
téléspectateurs s'ils étaient possibles
en théorie en tout cas n'étaient pas
documenté
par les parties
et puis votre conclusion monsieur le
Président sur l'importance de la de la
concurrence et sur l'articulation entre
politique industrielle et concurrence
qui est quand même le coeur du sujet
sur ce dossier comme sur comme sur
d'autres je suis absolument convaincu
qu'une politique de croissance de
l'économie française doit reposer sur
sur deux jambes dans le marché sur deux
jambes une politique industrielle qui
fixe les priorités collectives qui elle
ou les ressources de l'État et qui
protègent notre souveraineté et une
politique de la concurrence qui donne
leur chance aux nouveaux acteurs et qui
combat les rentes la concurrence sans
politique industrielle
mène à l'atomisation du marché et risque
d'ignorer l'intérêt collectif tel
qu'exprimée par le par l'État et par
vous
mais la politique industrielle sans
concurrence favorise les acteurs en
place et décourages innovation la
philosophie disons générale avec
laquelle j'ai abordé ce dossiers sur
lequel nous allons avoir l'occasion de
revenir
le sénateur hugonnais qui est rapporteur
des crédits du visuels a commencé par
vous poser les premières questions merci
président oui j'ai trois trois types de
questions on va dire monsieur le
Président dans son avis adressé à votre
autorité LARCOM avait indiqué de que des
remèdes raisonnables citons le couplage
des ventes pas de couplage de ventes de
publicité la séparation des régies la
session des chaînes supplémentaires
ces remèdes raisonnables d'irrais
raisonnables pouvaient permettre de
répondre aux préoccupations sectorielles
suscité par le projet de rapprochement
comment expliquer vous la divergence
d'analyses entre les deux autorités la
vôtre et l'arcome
par ailleurs n'aurait-il pas été
possible de signifier plutôt aux deux
sociétés l'impossibilité d'accepter
cette fusion au lieu de leur faire
perdre 18 mois et beaucoup d'argent
depuis le début il était acquis que les
marchés pertinents de la publicité
linéaire et des linéarisée n'était pas
complètement substituable pourquoi avoir
fait durer autant les choses ça c'est le
premier bloc le second c'est le groupe
Bertelsman qui semble décider à
poursuivre la session de M6 dans les
plus brefs délais plusieurs candidats
ont manifesté leur intérêt vendredi
dernier certains ayant déjà une présence
dans les médias et d'autres
pouvant être considérés comme de
nouveaux entrants
pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
différences qui s'appliquent dans
l'examen d'une candidature selon que
l'acheteur est ou non un acteur
important du secteur des médias quel
serait la durée minimale d'examen par
l'autorité selon que l'acheteur est
encore une fois ou non un acteur
important du secteur des médias et enfin
le troisième axe c'est l'autorité de la
concurrence à identifier dans son avis
de 2019
vous n'étiez pas président à cette
époque là mais c'est ta vie a été rendu
en 2019 donc de nombreuses asymétries
qui défavorisent les acteurs français
par rapport aux plateformes américaines
on peut penser à la souplesse dont
bénéficie les SMAD avec un taux global
d'obligation entre audiovisuelle et
cinéma
ainsi qu'à la possibilité pour les smats
d'obtenir des droits mondes
quel regard portez-vous sur la pertinent
la persistance pardon de ces asymétries
en 2022
n'est-il pas difficile de vouloir
limiter la concentration horizontale et
de maintenir des dispositions qui
empêchent les acteurs nationaux de
lutter à armes égales avec leur
concurrence américaine
Président je vous inviter à répondre
déjà à cette série de questions
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur alors je vais prendre vos
questions dans l'ordre sur la première
question qui est celle du
du calendrier et des messages envoyés
aux acteurs
je crois qu'il a été il a été clair dès
le début que cette opération
poserait des problèmes de concurrence
qui étaient éventuellement solvables
enfin il est le
il est il était clair et je crois il a
été dit au parti très clairement que
cette opération
serait difficile moi-même d'ailleurs
quand vous m'avez auditionné en fin
quand la commission économiquement
auditionnée en janvier j'ai dit c'est
une opération qui ne va pas de soi
de Silva avait eu des termes comparables
peut-être même plus encore plus clair
l'année dernière et donc de toute façon
il était clair que la question du marché
de la publicité serait
déterminante et il a été clair très vite
que la faisabilité de cette opération
reposait sur un
un acte de foi qui était la capacité
pour l'Autorité de la concurrence de
d'élargir la définition du marché et je
crois que Bouygues ont été conscient dès
le début par ailleurs sur en termes de
calendrier l'opération a été notifiée en
février et le rapport qui leur a été
envoyé en juillet
par les services d'instruction pas par
le collège donc ça n'engageait pas la
décision de l'autorité mais c'était
quand même
disons la masse de l'analyse et de fait
sur lesquels les vibrations du collège
elle est s'appuyer outre les écritures
des parties ce rapport était très
négatif ça a été rendu public et donc
dès le dès la fin du mois de juillet
les parties savaient que
leur leurs espoirs cet acte de foi dont
j'ai parlé serait
difficilement difficilement traduit dans
la réalité ils auraient pu retirer le
dossier en juillet ils ont choisi
d'aller au terme et de et de
de pouvoir se défendre devant le collège
ce qui était tout à fait leur droit et
la procédure tout à fait normale et on
l'a fait et je crois en respectant tout
à fait le contradictoire et le dans les
écrits dans leur capacité à répondre au
rapport écrit et ensuite dans les dans
les questions du collège les 5 et 6
septembre et
ils auraient pu aussi choisir de retirer
leur dossier plus tôt bon
sur le la divergence d'analyse avec
l'arcome alors d'abord je voudrais
peut-être rappeler qu'il y a eu aussi un
avis de la recette qui était beaucoup
plus
critique sur les marchés de la
distribution qui sont ceux qui
intéressent la recette et sur le risque
de de pouvoir de marcher excessif
vis-à-vis des notamment des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet et également sur le
risque
[Musique]
dit verticale de traitement privilégié
de Bouygues Telecom par rapport aux
autres fournisseurs d'accès Internet
puisque le
l'entreprise acquéreuse possède un
fournisseur d'accès Internet
sur l'arcome bon d'abord il est pas
forcément
gênant qu'on ait des divergences
d'analyses avec là avec leur homme
puisqu'on n'a pas le même mandat
de l'arcom c'est le le
l'équilibre du secteur et aussi sa
capacité à assurer le la pluralité des
programmes et particulièrement de la
formation mais pas seulement vous en
discuterez demain avec le président de
la reconnais donc je veux pas parler à
sa place alors que l'Autorité de la
concurrence au centre strictement sur le
le les questions de concurrence en
l'occurrence les problèmes je pense
identifiés étaient les mêmes là où il y
a eu divergence c'est sur la capacité de
ces remèdes
comportementaux à
éliminer les risques donc là le collège
de l'Autorité de la Concurrence a
considéré que ces remèdes n'étaient pas
suffisants pour la raison que j'avais
exposée qui est que quel que soit les
les modalités de gouvernance
les incitations économiques des deux
régies aurait été alignés et donc elles
auraient travailler de concerts
explicitement ou implicitement mais mais
en poursuivant les mêmes intérêts donc
là il y a eu là il y a eu une clairement
divergence mais ça mais le l'analyse des
des problèmes suscités par l'opération
n'étaient pas fondamentalement
différente
sur sur
berthollzman est-ce qu'il va se passer
maintenant sur sur la saison 2 de ce
dossier si j'ose dire bon nous on a été
saisi de rien donc je
pas du tout commenté des
acquéreurs potentiels parce que on n'a
pas été saisi à ma connaissance la
commission non plus n'a pas été saisie
je comprends que ça sera fait dans les
prochains jours mais ça c'est à
burtlesman de le dire
le les acquéreurs d'une part en termes
de de
répartition entre l'aiguillages entre la
Commission et le et le
et le et l'Autorité de la concurrence
compte tenu de la taille des acquéreurs
potentiels tels qu'ils ont été
mentionnés dans la presse et là encore
je me réfère à la presse puisqu'on a pas
d'information particulière là-dessus
il est la logique voudrait que cette
opération soit examinée par la
commission européenne alors il a la
possibilité de nous le renvoyer et on va
voir ce qui se passe dans les prochains
jours ou semaines en fonction de la
nature du de l'acquéreur et des
dispositions de la Commission européenne
je pense qu'il y a une probabilité
importante que cette opération soit
examinée par la commission et pas par
nous voilà
toujours en vertu de la réglementation
des deux tiers de chiffre d'affaires
alors c'est un peu plus bon c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça les deux tiers du
chiffre d'affaires c'est une exe une
exemption à une règle qui dit que
si le total du chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises mondiales des entreprises
concernées je dis ça sous le contrôle de
mon collègue qui connaissait mieux que
moi en tout cas les chiffres
dépassent 5 milliards d'euros au niveau
mondial
et si et dépasse également 250 millions
d'euros dans au moins deux pays de
l'Union européenne à ce moment-là c'est
la Commission qui examine sauf si les
entreprises concernées réalisent
chacune plus de deux tiers de leur
chiffre d'affaires dans un même pays ce
qui était le cas en l'espèce pour
Bouygues et et
M6 je sais pas
M6 M6 M6 et métropoles télévisions
métropoles Télévisions qui étaient le
vendeur le vendeur n'était pas à
bertholtzman la cible n'était pas
berthelsman mais métropole métropole
télévision
de renouvellement des autorisations
à savoir mais 2023 selon les acquéreurs
possibles ce calendrier ne pourrait pas
être tenu c'est très tendu et là
vraiment je préférerais
que vous posiez la question à recoliser
messe puisque c'est lui le enfin il y a
une sorte de rétroplanning si vous
voulez c'est lui qui est maître de la de
ce qui va se passer en 2023 et de la
décision finale qui est celle du
renouvellement de la licence donc c'est
vraiment à lui de vous répondre mais
je pense que oui si l'opération ne nous
est pas notifié avant disons la fin
octobre ça va être très difficile je
pense qu'on peut résumer comme ça
donc le calendrier je dis pas que c'est
pas faisable mais c'est dans tous les
cas de figure très tendus
voilà pour pour berthollzman
et sur la ville 2019 alors bon je peux
faire une réponse courte ou très longue
monsieur le Président parce que il y a
beaucoup de dimensions
très rapidement pour pour rebondir sur
ce que vous venez de dire cette tension
sur le calendrier serait la même et
c'était l'objet de ma question aussi que
ça soit un professionnel de ce secteur
ou que ça soit quelqu'un qui un nouvel
entrant on va dire
je vais non non oui je vais être très
prudent dans ma réponse parce que cette
audition est publique il y a des
entreprises
côté derrière donc voilà et là encore
nous on est passé d'aucun dossier donc
toute notre discussions se font sur les
informations qui sont
qui sont disponibles dans la presse
ça peut être plus ou moins facile selon
le l'empreinte de l'acquéreur dans le
dans le secteur audiovisuel mais tout ça
étant tout de même et il peut y avoir
également des effets d'autres effets
dit verticaux ou congloméraux en
fonction de ses autres activités
dans la radio dans la presse dans des
dans des secteurs qui ne sont pas la
télévision mais qui sont disons qui sont
disons connexes
tout ça étant je dirais tempéré par le
fait que la définition des marchés est
clairement national
autrement dit le marché de la télévision
c'est les Français s'il y a pas de
marché de la télévision européen pour du
point de vue des téléspectateurs donc ça
peut ça peut limiter certains de ses
effets
ce que je dis peut-être un peu critique
mais c'est très difficile d'en dire plus
sans donner des noms
peut-être en deux mots et puis je suis à
vos dispositions pour pour approfondir
sur certains points
la ville 2019 a été notre point de
départ de notre réflexion bien sûr
puisque c'est le il a il a cristallisé
la position de l'autorité sur le secteur
audiovisuel il est pas si vieux que ça
même si beaucoup de choses se sont
passées depuis 2019 y compris comme vous
le rappeliez au cours des derniers mois
mais c'est ça a été notre base la ville
constatait un certain nombre
d'évolutions et notamment le
développement rapide des plateformes de
vidéo à la demande ça ça a été
évidemment confirmé ça c'est même
accéléré par rapport à ce qui était
anticipé en 2019
et on a eu des évolutions annoncées qui
n'étaient pas dans la ville de 2019
évidemment mais qui était qui ont été
pris qui qui sont publics et qui ont des
prises en compte dans nos analyses comme
le
[Musique]
la diffusion les projets de Netflix de
une offre
moins cher avec de la publicité dont les
contours sont pas encore très précis les
chiffres qui sont donnés viennent de
disons de d'observateurs tiers on n'a
pas de chiffre très fiable enfin bon on
peut se baser sur les ordres de grandeur
qui ont été rappelés puisque c'est ce
qu'on a tous
également le l'entrée d'Amazon sur le la
diffusion des d'Amazon prime sur le
sur la Ligue 1 l'expérience du match de
Roland-Garros diffusé par Amazon avec de
la publicité
avant et après donc tout ça a été pris
en compte
ça n'a pas conduit à changer la
définition du marché pourquoi d'une part
parce que le fait que les plateformes
rentrent dans la publicité ne veut pas
dire que le marché est le même
ce qui compte à la fin c'est la manière
dont les dans les annonceurs vont
utiliser ces différents supports
ce que nous ont dit les annonceurs et ça
n'est pas ce qu'on dit TF1 M6 bien sûr
mais ce que nous ont dit les annonceurs
au terme du test de marché c'est les
usages restent différents c'est ces
usages sont complémentaires ils ne sont
pas substituables le les plateformes
vont aller vers de la publicité qui est
qui est ciblé parce qu'ils avaient elles
vont utiliser toute l'information
qu'elles ont sur les sur les sur les sur
leur consommateurs sur leur
téléspectateurs quand on regarde il y a
beaucoup de gens qui regardent Netflix
au même moment le soir mais ils
regardent tous des programmes différents
alors que les gens qui regardent le
programme le journal télévisé de TF1 ou
de M6
regarde tous et d'ailleurs souvent en
famille le même programme et donc ça
crée une puissance d'écran qui n'est pas
allé avec laquelle les plateformes ne
rivalisent pas sauf exception donc oui
peut-être que la publicité autour de
d'un match de Ligue 1 autour d'un match
de tennis sur Amazon s'apparente à de la
publicité télévisuel parce que c'est
aussi c'est des événements fédérateurs
regardés par beaucoup de monde en même
temps et donc elle peut elle peut être
substituée à pour certains annonceurs
d'une publicité à la télé mais ça n'est
pas le cas général aujourd'hui et je
pense et là c'est peut-être un point un
peu plus un peu plus philosophique
monsieur le Président mais
que les industriels et l'Autorité de la
concurrence ne raisonne pas de la même
manière sur ces évolutions c'est à dire
que les industriels veulent et c'est
leur devoirs préparer le scénario du
pire qui serait un scénario de
d'édiction du marché de la publicités au
bénéfice des plateformes donc ils ont
ils ont le 2 ils ont le devoir vis-à-vis
de leurs actionnaires et leurs salariés
d'investir pour prévenir ces scénarios
et pour gérer tous ces risques
potentiels pour eux dans les meilleures
conditions c'est absolument normal qu'il
le fassent nous nous raisonnons sur la
base de scénario probable nos raisons
pas sur la base du pire scénario pour le
l'industriel concerné et c'est pas du
tout la même approche la question que
nous nous sommes posées c'est est-ce que
le scénario ou un horizon raisonnable
qui peut être de 3 ans de 5 ans après on
peut discuter de l'horizon le
le les annonceurs
utiliseraient puiserez de manière
complètement indifférente et substituée
dans les inventaires en ligne ou dans
les inventaires à la télé ce scénario
mais aujourd'hui pas le plus probable
aujourd'hui voilà et je comprends que
les industriels veulent se prémunir
contre lui mais c'est pas la même
logique c'est pas la même logique
sénateur c'est que sur la ville 2019 il
y avait également ça nous amène
peut-être à d'autres questions qui
seront donc je
pourrais développer plus tard dans la
vie 2019 il y avait aussi un certain
nombre de réflexions d'autorité de la
concurrence sur le cadre réglementaire
et ça répond à votre dernière question à
ce sénateur et sur la manière dont le
cadre réglementaire pourrait évoluer
pour permettre aux acteurs français de
se développer dans les meilleures
conditions et donc ça touchait le
calendrier des médias a touché d'avoir
des sujets qu'on va pas discuter
aujourd'hui mais comme le
l'interdiction de publicité pour les
pour les films qui a été levé d'ailleurs
en tout cas titre expérimental
et voilà ça touchait un certain nombre
de
s'as touchés aussi
d'une manière générale et je m'arrêterai
là la manière de d'inclure dans ses
obligations les acteurs en ligne et le
faire en sorte que ces obligations
réglementaires celles de la loi de 86 et
les autres ne s'applique pas seulement
aux acteurs de la télévision française
qui effectivement créé un handicap
concurrentiel c'est ce qu'on disait en
2019 et ça reste l'actualité
tout dernier
sur le fait que la publicité était quand
même au centre de la décision alors que
là je notais c'est bien le sujet
d'avenir c'est la symétrie et pas la
publicité qui donnons-nous quelques
années et on va voir si on en sera la
même ça avance à patcher donc c'était
vraiment la symétrie que je n'étais plus
que la publicité David hassouline et
Monique de Marco
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de l'Autorité de
la concurrence je veux vous dire que
le travail que vous fournissez dans le
domaine que nous suivons concernant
l'audiovisuel ou alors la presse
précédemment puisque nous avons eu aussi
à apprécier votre travail quand on a
légiféré sur les droits voisins et
absolument remarquable
pour une raison c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de doutes en général qui s'installe sur
les institutions voir les autorités
et sur leur caractère indépendant
à l'évidence on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord sur ce que vous avez rendu
comme avis ça c'est voilà c'est c'est
légitime mais
vu
ce qui était écrit ou décrit comme
scénario inévitable et
déjà écrit d'avance
et démenti par votre rendu voilà donc ça
prouve que vous avez travaillé à partir
de vos critères et non pas en fonction
de ce qui a pu se dire comme déjà joué
vu les enjeux
et c'est ça fait plaisir parce que dans
le domaine de la démocratie quand on est
conforté dans le fait qu'il y a des
autorités il y a des institutions dans
notre pays qui fonctionnent qui peuvent
résister à des puissances comme Google
quand il s'agissait des droits voisins
et infliger des des amandes tout à fait
conséquentes et dissuasifs pour les
obliger à rentrer dans le cadre de ce
qu'est notre État de droit et de notre
législation en termes de concurrence
économique et là je répète quel que soit
la vie qu'on pouvait avoir sur cela
c'est un avis indépendant et qui a
surpris beaucoup de monde dans les
choses avaient l'air de être écrite
sur le plan vous savez que nous on a
fait une commission d'enquête qu'on a
auditionné votre prédécesseuse
puis votre
prédécesseur intérimaire et que j'ai
j'avais acquis la conviction que si on
restait sur le marché tel qu'il avait
été analysé jusqu'à présent et
travailler dans dans par vous
il n'y avait pas de possibilité de dire
oui donc il fallait accepter de changer
le marché pertinent échanger la
jurisprudence de vos rendus pour pouvoir
dire oui à cette fusion
vous avez jugé
que le marché pertinent n'avait pas
changé
mais
monsieur le Président en ouverture de
séance a dit que il reste quelques
chantiers parce que
le numérique de peut pas se confondre à
l'audiovisuel c'est un peu ce que vous
dites
mais il y a une zone d'intersection
et il faudra bien aussi qui est des
règles sur cette zone d'intersection
sinon
justement les plateformes ou un champ
aussi
où ils n'ont pas de de limite où tous
les cas de règles suffisamment fortes
pour permettre dans le champ de
l'audiovisuel numérique c'est à dire de
cette intersection à nos entreprises
d'être en situation concurrentielle donc
c'est un chantier ouvert mais vous
n'avez pas voulu
vous le définir sans son cadre et débat
qui permettent de le circonstanquer très
exactement donc écoutez c'était une
première remarque la
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
même si vous nous avez dit et d'ailleurs
je veux relever le paradoxe que
normalement vous étiez là pour juger de
la concurrence économique et l'arcade
était là pour juger de la pertinence ou
de la
légitimité démocratique et pluraliste or
je vois dans le rendu de l'arcom des
considérations économiques où elle juge
différemment de vous donc dans un champ
qui est plutôt de votre compétence mais
ne rien dire sur les les
difficultés qui pouvaient y avoir sur le
champ du pluralisme etc que vous vous
avez relevé dans votre introduction
comme étant aussi la pluralité de
l'offre un des sujets sur lequel vous
êtes bon j'ai l'impression qu'on afro
reversé mais ça ça
me permettra d'interroger demain matin
sur pour cette sur cet avis de la com
qui est un peu surprenant parce qu'il ne
traite pas du sujet
suffisamment sur lequel il est
interpellé la régulation des
démocratique est pluraliste
des choses
ma question elle est précise sur
je sais que vous pouvez botter en touche
mais sur les nouveaux acquéreurs
possibles
parce que
on en connaît trois qui sont sur est-ce
que vous savez si ça passera par vous
par la Commission européenne
parce que je ne connais pas leur chiffre
d'affaires ou leur bénéfice à l'étranger
par rapport à ceux qui les réalisés en
France mais
16 médias une veste
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à la louche
le projet de Stéphane courby qui est
quand même associé aussi à Rodolphe Saad
bon et puis Xavier Niel c'est que
l'italien média for Europe
bon donc en gros ce que je vous pose
comme question c'est est-ce que vous
allez vous pensez que il y aura un
contournement par ce ces nouveaux
montages
pour que ce ne soit pas de votre
autorité mais de celui de l'Europe
de bas
voilà donc il y a quand même deux
questions à ce que vous pensez que la
législation doit évoluer sur cette zone
grise on va dire parce que il y a un
vrai sujet quand même et la deuxième sur
les nouveaux acquéreurs possibles et la
possibilité de contourner le fait que ce
soit l'Autorité de la concurrence qui
qui statue de main sur ce dossier
prendre plusieurs questions monsieur le
Président si vous voulez bien Monique de
Marco et ensuite Sylvie Robert merci
bonjour monsieur le Président bon
écoutez c'est une question de
compréhension vous avez bien parlé de
l'incompatibilité sur les parts de
marché publicitaires de la fusion M6 TF1
mais vous avez aussi évoqué deux autres
raisons vous avez dit qu'en définitive
votre avis a été motivé par
l'analyse du marché de distribution et
également par le marché d'acquisition de
droit et de contenu
autant il est possible donc d'évaluer la
part de marché publicitaire mais
pouvez-vous me dire comment vous évaluez
justement qu'est-ce qui a justifié
comment avez-vous fait pour pouvoir
apporter des éléments concernant ces
deux autres raisons je vous remercie
monsieur le Président moi je vais aller
un petit peu au-delà dans notre
réflexion pour vous demander la chose
suivante la Commission européenne a
dévoilé il y a peu de temps sa
proposition de législation sur la
liberté des médias le média freedom Act
donc ce règlement européen consacre le
pour la première fois en fait le
principe de pluralisme des médias et
porte aussi sur le phénomène de
concentration dans dans le secteur donc
je rappelle que l'idée fondamentale est
de faire en sorte que les États membres
dépassent le seul champ économique pour
analyser justement les les différents
mouvements concentrationnels et mesurent
l'impact en matière de pluralisme et
d'indépendance éditoriale en quelque
sorte je dirais que il pourrait s'agir
d'effectuer une forme d'analyse d'impact
démocratique je sais pas si on peut le
dire comme ça mais si le projet de la
commission arrive à son terme c'est
quand même extrêmement important donc je
voudrais vous demander puisque
l'Autorité de la concurrence est
concernée quand même au premier chef
quel regard vous portez sur cette
proposition de la Commission européenne
puis j'irai plus loin à ce que vous y
êtes favorable
vous laissez répondre à cette question
merci monsieur le Président merci de me
laisser répondre maintenant parce que on
allait arriver au point où j'allais
oublier les premières questions ce qui
aurait été très ennuyeux
donc je commence par par le sénateur à
souligne sur sur le
sur le
bon je vais pas commenter sur le fait
qu'on soit affront renversé avec l'air
comme je crois pas alors on a des
on a des angles différents les les
propositions d'engagement de l'arcom
était bienvenus le collège a considéré
que ça n'allait pas assez loin mais ça
ça contribué du même de la participer de
la même préoccupation donc il y avait
pas de désaccord fondamental simplement
on a on a considéré que ça serait pas
suffisant voilà le s'agissant du
pluralisme je voudrais clarifier que le
fait que le l'Autorité de la concurrence
n'a aucune compétence en matière de
pluralisme politique par exemple ça
c'est clair complètement du côté de
l'arcom voilà nous avons nous nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la diversité
alors vous allez dire que je joue avec
les mots et que entre la digue de la
diversité au pluralisme et à peut-être
voilà une forme de
de continuum
la diversité est un paramètre de
concurrence le maintien de la diversité
de l'offre dans sur n'importe quel
marché est très important l'Autorité de
la concurrence ne s'intéresse pas
seulement au prix on s'intéresse à la
diversité surtout les marchés pour les
consommateurs ou les entreprises quand
c'est les entreprises qui qui achètent
les produits et on l'a regardé sur ce
dossier et notamment on a examiné
sur le marché des acquisitions et je
vais y revenir dans un instant puisque
la question a été posée le risque que le
nouvel acquéreur
achète
et donc un pouvoir de
d'acquisition plus fort un pouvoir de
marcher plus fort à l'achat et donc face
BC par exemple le prix individuel des
films commandés par les chaînes
peut-être au détriment de la qualité ça
fait partie des effets que les services
d'instructions ont regardé et également
le le la circulation potentielle des
œuvres dans le nouvel ensemble TF1 M6
qui aurait permis de
acheter peut-être moins d'oeuvre et
ensuite de les faire circuler dans un
ensemble plus grand donc potentiellement
aussi au
détriment de la diversité ça c'est des
choses qu'on a regardé et qui ont été
importantes sur l'évolution plus
générale du secteur les chantiers pour
le secteur je crois que là encore je
peux revenir à notre avis 2019 qui
disait en gros
il était pas donc je prends des libertés
avec le texte de la vie que j'ai que
j'ai
occasion j'ai pas participé enfin qui
disait en gros la loi de 86 ne n'est
plus adapté à la réalité de la
concurrence dans le secteur qui implique
qui allait le dispositif était très
centré autour des chaînes de la TNT et
des vidence les acteurs maintenant est
beaucoup plus large et donc il faudrait
faire évoluer un certain nombre de
concepts dans la vie 2019 on mentionné
électricité le rôle du plafond de 49%
pour la détention des chaînes
on mentionnait le
la limitation des autorisations TNT qui
n'a plus dans le sens sur un marché ou
la TNT n'est plus le périmètre du du
marché et on parlait également de du
dispositif anti-concentration de la de
la loi de 86 je parle pas de du rôle de
l'Autorité de la concurrence mais du
dispositif
notamment du du dispositif 2 sur 3 qui
est dans la loi de 86 et on disait
également que il faudrait envisager de
l'adapter pour l'appliquer à l'ensemble
des acteurs et d'ailleurs dans vos dans
votre dans le rapport de votre
commission d'enquête j'ai noté les
propositions
31 et 32 qui vont tout à fait dans ce
sens de l'élargissement du périmètre à
des acteurs qui sont pas forcément des
chaînes de la TNT donc ça c'est quelque
chose que d'ailleurs qu'on peut auquel
on peut réfléchir à nouveau si vous le
souhaitez puisque c'est tout à fait dans
notre rôle mais qui certainement pour
nous irait dans la bonne direction sur
les nouveaux acquéreurs alors là je vais
encore je vous allez trader sur une
réponse parce que je vais vraiment pas
commenter des
des acquéreurs potentiels et ça va
dépendre beaucoup aussi de la structure
du montage capitalistique du rôle de
contrôle ou pas de contrôle etc les
différents participants et on a aucune
information là-dessus donc c'est très
difficile de raisonner là-dessus je
constate simplement que au vu des noms
dont on parle dans la presse que les
leurs chiffres d'affaires mondiale les
frais plutôt penchés du côté de la
Commission européenne voilà bon
ça peut changer en fonction de
la définition précise du montage
financier et puis ensuite de la décision
que prendra la commission mais là encore
comme je disais tout à l'heure ça change
pas fondamentalement le calendrier ça le
rend un peu plus probablement un peu
plus tendu mais il sera déjà tendu même
avec nous donc voilà c'est pas
et par ailleurs le mécanisme du renvoi
si la commission décidait de nous
renvoyer le dossier lui-même est
générateur de délai supplémentaires ce
qu'il faut il faut un certain temps pour
la demande de renvoi et pour le il y a
des délais réglementaires du côté de la
commission qui doivent être de quoi
trois semaines quelque chose comme ça
donc voilà 15 euros vrai donc ça rajoute
15 euros vrai dans un calendrier qui est
déjà très tendu
mais voilà je suis très difficile d'en
dire plus sans sans connaître les noms
sur les sur les autres marchés que la
publicité donc la question de la
sénatrice donc il y avait principalement
deux marchés qui ont été regardés
c'était
outre la publicité c'était donc la
distribution et donc le les relations
entre le nouvel ensemble et les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet et
d'autres distributeurs qui distribuent
TF1 et M6 sur la plateforme donc je
pense à Canal+ par exemple
et là le risque principal qui a été
identifié par le collège
c'était je peux parler au nom du collège
je veux pas commenter un rapport
d'instruction qui n'engage pas le
collège et qui n'a jamais été rendu
public mais je peux vous dire ce que
penser le collège ce qui est finalement
ce qui compte à la fin parce qu'on en a
délibéré longuement on a considéré qu'il
y avait un risque matériel de
que le nouvel ensemble utilise son
pouvoir de marché vis-à-vis des
distributeurs tout ce confondus est FAI
et autres pour augmenter les redevances
de distribution
et qui avait également un risque
potentiel peut-être plus difficile à
caractériser mais qui avait été relevé
dans la vie de l'ARCEP et qui
préoccupait larcep de
de traitement
privilégiés de Bouygues Telecom par le
nouvel ensemble par rapport aux autres
pays donc ces risques là pour être
complètement honnête aurait pu se
traiter par des engagements
spécifiques donc c'était pas
insurmontable ça aurait appelé des
engagements des engagements de non
discrimination des FAI par le nouvel
ensemble et des choses comme ça on n'est
pas allé jusqu'à cette discussion
puisque le la question de la publicité
de toute façon a été dirigeante mais
si la question s'était posée je pense
qu'il y aurait eu des solutions sur les
marchés de contenu il y a deux
principalement enfin si on essaie de de
d'organiser cette discussion il y avait
les programmes de flux et les programmes
de stock donc les programmes de flux je
diffusion sportive etc
ou il y avait un risque qui avait été
identifié qui était là aussi difficile à
caractériser mais possible de
d'internalisation par le nouvel ensemble
de la production des programmes de flux
au détriment de des producteurs actuels
des programmes de flux de type jeu
programme toutes sortes de programmes
d'actualité en direct etc voilà c'est un
risque qui avait été signalé dans le
test de marché qui nous a été à nouveau
signalé lors des auditions
je pense que je dirais que c'est un
risque de moindre ampleur que tout ce
qu'on vient de parler notamment la
publicité mais c'était un risque
potentiel et sur les contenus de stock
il y avait probablement très peu de
risques du côté des programmes du côté
des films étrangers et notamment des
films américains puisque là c'est un
marché mondial le nouvel ensemble aurait
pas pesé
aurait pas eu un pouvoir de marcher très
important sur le marché mondial de
l'acquisition des signes américains il y
avait un risque potentiel sur les
marques sur l'acquisition des films
français mais là il s'agit comme vous le
savez très bien d'un marché qui est très
encadré réglement par les obligations
d'acquisition qui s'imposent désormais
aussi aux plateformes et par et par le
calendrier des médias donc le
l'intensité de ce risque était d'une
certaine manière
moindre du fait de ces de ses
obligations réglementaires qui
d'une certaine manière limite la
concurrence sur ce marché puisque tout
est la réglementation fixe des limites à
ce qui peut être fait ce qui ne ce qui
ne peut pas être fait
et enfin sur le
la proposition
sur le média fredomac et
la question d'impact démocratique là je
vraiment je renverrai à Olivier Mestre
qui est compétent voilà vous faut lui
poser la question
du point de vue là encore de la
diversité nous on peut être que
favorable à des règles
anti-concentration
harmonisée au niveau européen et qui
favorise la diversité donc un niveau
assez abstrait je pourrais vous répondre
que oui on y est favorable
il y a pas d'autres inscrits mais moi je
voudrais vous poser de deux qui assis
lors d'un
et puis je compléterai par deux
questions là pardon monsieur le
Président non non je voulais juste en
fait revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
sur la TNT est-ce que
la décision que vous avez prise ne va
pas tuer à terme la TNT gratuite en
affaiblissant les principales chaînes de
chaîne privée et deuxièmement vous avez
parlé aussi du fait que vous n'étiez pas
là pour appliquer une politique
industrielle mais qui finalement
est un enfin étant mesure de le faire
quand on a ce genre de de situation
voilà
question je voulais poser alors aussi
sur la politique industrielle parce que
nous avons noté que votre propos
liminaire se terminait en disant qu'il
doit y avoir deux jambes dans une
décision de cette nature la définition
de la politique industrielle et puis le
respect des règles de concurrence
évidemment sur le respect des règles de
concurrence ça relevait de votre
autorité en revanche sur la politique
industrielle vous avez je crois dit dans
un interview que ce n'était pas votre
rôle de faire la politique industrielle
vous savez qu'il y a un certain débat
qui naît depuis ces derniers jours sur
le fait que la décision que vous alliez
prendre aurait eu un aura un impact
industriel important effectivement ça
pose la question de est-ce que vous avez
senti sur ce sur ce dossier sur ce
marché qui n'est pas un marché comme un
autre est-ce qu'il y a une définition
d'une politique industrielle qui vous
est apparu pour allant dans un sens ou
dans un autre d'ailleurs mais est-ce que
elle apparaît clairement épique deuxième
question que je voulais vous poser
on sait que la décision de l'autorité
était recruter dans d'autres pays
puisque le groupe bertholzman
commençait la réorganisation du secteur
européen par la vente de M6 mais
d'autres projets de vente par ailleurs
est-ce que vous avez eu des contacts
avec vos homologues des autorités de la
concurrence dans les autres pays
concernés pour qu'il y ait une certaine
harmonisation des points de vue
alors une dernière question
c'est un chantier
autre mais
vous a sous la main comme on dit
parce que dans votre décision vous
mettez un terme à un projet de
concentration plus important dans un
secteur de l'audiovisuel et nous savons
que
d'autres industriels dans le secteur des
médias
amplifient leur concentration les temps
à l'édition et il faudrait peut-être
aussi s'occuper d'eux comme on dirait
et notamment dans le domaine de
l'édition il y a des très fortes
inquiétudes
y compris en termes de concurrence
je sais que c'est ça passe par l'Europe
mais quand même pouvez-vous nous dire de
mots sur comment vous appréciez ça et
s'il y a un moment donné vous êtes
saisis du dossier vous vous en saisissez
vous-même parce que là les inquiétudes
deviennent
urgentes c'est-à-dire qu'en gros ma
question c'est bon bah là il y a une
concentration il y a eu un regard mais
il faudrait ne pas laisser libre cours
qu'ailleurs ça se fasse en toute
impunité de façon sauvage
je pense pas je pense pas d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs TF1 et M6
sont des chaînes qui vont bien enfin
c'est ce qu'elles disent alors à leurs
actionnaires et leurs investisseurs dans
leur communication financière qu'elle
voudrait n'ont jamais elles sont jamais
elles n'ont jamais allé aussi bien n'ont
jamais été en aussi bonne forme
financière et c'est ce qu'elle disent et
[Musique]
j'ai aucun doute que les deux chaînes
alors TMC en fonction évidemment de ces
évolutions dont on vient de parler
ce
se réinventeront pour s'adapter aux
défis technologiques je pense que il est
évident que l'avenir des chaînes c'est
[Musique]
évidemment d'entretenir de garder la
recette publicitaires ce qui dépend pas
entièrement d'elle et là conjoncture
publicitaire est pas très bonne il va
pas s'améliorer pour des raisons
macroéconomiques on va dire dans les
mois qui viennent
de
d'avoir des bons programmes ça c'est
leur boulot et de d'avoir des
technologies qui sont adaptées aux
usages à l'évolution des usages et c'est
un peu de c’était un peu au centre de
cette discussion et donc toutes les j'ai
pas de doute que ces chaînes vont
développer des interfaces
elles en elles les ont déjà d'ailleurs
elles ont été F1 elles ont etc mais
elles vont je pense qu'elles vont
réinventer ces interfaces pour avoir des
interfaces qui peuvent être accessibles
directement aux consommateurs et
proposer dans des bouquets être
accessibles directement sur Internet
permettre une fidélisation du
téléspectateur permettent aussi
d'accumuler des données sur le
téléspectateur qui permettront également
de mieux cibler leur offre elle le font
elles ont les moyens de le faire et le
je pense pas là je vais passer un
jugement de nature industrielle donc
j'ai peut-être tort parce que c'est pas
mon métier si vous voulez mais je pense
pas que l'opération en elle-même qui
était la fusion et tfm6 changer
fondamentalement la donne ça aurait
dégagé des ressources oui ça aurait créé
des synergies qui auraient dégagé des
ressources pour cette transformation
technologique c'est ce qu'ils ont
expliqué mais d'une part une partie de
ces ressources aurait été gagnées aux
dépens de leur distributeur et de leurs
annonceurs par augmentation de leur
tarifs donc ça c'était ça qui nous qui
était un souci pour nous
et par ailleurs ces ressources de toute
façon ne sont
ne sont pas disons du même ordre de
grandeur que les ressources que l'on
dispose Netflix Disney ou ou Amazon sur
les mêmes marchés donc c'était pas ça
aurait pas fondamentalement changé la
donne c'était ça faisait du sens pour
eux et je comprends très bien qu'il les
fait mais c'était pas ça allait pas
révolutionner la situation
concurrentielle entre la télévision
gratuite et les et les plateformes en
ligne je remarque d'ailleurs quand on
parle beaucoup de la concurrence de
Netflix
à ma connaissance Netflix n'est pas né
de la fusion de deux chaînes de
télévision Netflix elle était un service
de
d'envoi de DVD à domicile en 98 99 qui
ensuite est devenu une un service de de
VOD donc c'est que ça a commencé tout
petit donc la question qu'on doit se
poser et puisqu'on parle de politique
industrielle et je vais y venir c'est
aussi comment est-ce qu'on crée comment
est-ce qu'on fournit à nos entreprises
en France un cadre qui permet
l'apparition d'un nouveau Netflix
Netflix n'a pas n'est pas résulter de la
fusion de CBS et de Fox Netflix c'est
des gens qui ont une idée
entrepreneuriale qui était de d'envoyer
des DVD chez les gens et ça a marché et
ça et ils se sont su s'adapter à la
technologie et ils sont devenus ce qui
sont pour moi l'enjeu pour la France
c'est de pouvoir de permettre ça c'est
de permettre ce genre de ce genre de
démarche et on l'a d'ailleurs on a des
licornes dans toutes sortes de secteurs
donc c'est possible c'est possible voilà
c'est possible si c'est européen mais
c'est une question qui dépasse largement
la concurrence qui est aussi une
question fiscale une question de marché
du travail etc donc pour peut-être pour
en venir à la politique industrielle
le pour moi et d'ailleurs c'est assez
suggéré par toutes les questions que
vous avez posées pour moi l'enjeu c'est
de discuter des évolutions du cadre
réglementaire et beaucoup d'entre elles
ne nous concerneront pas nous mais je
vais la recommande je pense aura un avis
plus éclairé qui permet de rétablir un
terrain de jeu égal entre les chaînes
actuelles et notamment les chaînes de la
TNT et les grands acteurs numériques et
donc comment est-ce qu'on assujetti les
grands acteurs numériques à des règles
comparables à celles qui sont
aujourd'hui notamment dans la dans la
loi de 86 pour moi c'est plutôt ça la
priorité pour le reste les groupes sont
des groupes privés qui ont des
actionnaires privés et qui ont les
moyens de se développer
sur votre dernière question monsieur le
Président sur les ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays il y a on a été en
contact avec les autres autorités de
concurrence on a été en contact avec la
commission naturellement vous savez
qu'au sein du réseau européen de
concurrence il y a une forme de
transparence sur la manière dont on
traite les dossiers donc on a beaucoup
d'échanges et on a particulièrement
échangé avec l'Autorité de la
concurrence néerlandaise qui est en
train de traiter un cas très similaire
et également avec l'Autorité de la
concurrence belge qui elle a déjà conclu
mais la le marché belge est différent
parce qu'il y a le évidemment une
segmentation linguistique qui fait que
le les marchés ne sont pas organisés de
la même manière et avec l'autorité
l'Autorité de la concurrence
néerlandaise je peux pas
travailler à la substance de nos
discussions mais on a échangé y compris
au plan méthodologique sur les
instruments et les données qui nous
permettent qui nous permettaient
d'analyser le la convergence des marchés
et la définition des marchés
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
n'en vois pas je ne reste maintenant à
vous remercier monsieur le Président des
réponses que vous devez apporter encore
une fois de la rapidité que vous avez
mise à nous à répondre à notre
invitation je crois que c'est ces
informations que vous avez données
étaient tout à fait utile pour notre
compréhension de ce qui s'est passé puis
aussi pour préparer l'audition que nous
aurons demain avec Rock Olivier Metz
merci monsieur le président